it's great to welcome back to the
program today dr. Michael Shermer who's
the publisher of skeptic magazine and a
New York Times bestselling author his
latest book is giving the devil his due
reflections of a scientific humanist
it's so great to have you back on nice
to be back on David nice to see you so
these are strange times and I mean just
just to sort of open things up what have
the last couple of months revealed to
you if anything about humanity that you
maybe did not consider as deeply before
in terms of our ability to deal with
calamity about our leaders about really
anything I mean just where is your mind
right now
yeah I'd say first of all people for the
most part have been pretty good about
social social isolation and and you know
staying down in one place you know
there's a few handful of protesters with
their Confederate flags or swastikas
and-and-and semi-automatic rifles that
people point to but that's that's pretty
rare I think most people particularly in
California where I matter are pretty
good on the negative side I'd say it's a
sign of how fragile and networked the
economy is how quickly things can kind
of unravel and there's no mystery about
it we know exactly why the economy is
collapsed and but it does show you to
what extent it it's all sort of propped
up by all of us doing our thing you know
just kind of a collective action by
individual action and how what happens
when everybody stops even when they
don't want to how fast that can unravel
although as Adam Smith famously said
there's a lot of ruin in a nation so I
don't think we're on the brink of the
the apocalypse or anything like that but
obviously we we have to get back to work
at some point here in that the first
probably bit by June or July certainly
by the end of the summer before things
really get pretty serious in that regard
just based on the numbers I'd say I'm a
little bit worried this morning that the
death rate is not plummeted like I
thought it would when the testing went
up I thought
with mass testing the denominator would
go way up and therefore the that that
percentage of death would go down to
more like one percent but it's still it
like 5.8 percent this morning in the
United States and about seven percent
worldwide so it's possible more testing
will change that and get it back down to
something like a serious flu but right
at the month at the moment it's it's not
just a bad flu it's way worse than that
so I think the social isolation thing
was the right move yeah and of course
when we look at the antibody tests we
have to assume at least from what we see
so far that the real case denominator is
certainly at least a couple of times
higher than the real number of cases but
a lot of we really won't know until
later in terms of the in terms of the
protesters a little bit I've not been
giving it too much oxygen in terms of
the individuals I've been more just
thinking about the the public health
implications and the guidelines that are
being put out there you and I have
talked about these issues of free speech
and suppression of speech before you've
been critical of right and left for
suppressing speech is the entire thing
of these protests really even an issue
of free speech at all in your mind
because you very quickly see protesters
who say being told I can't be out
gathering and protesting violates my
constitutional right to assemble and to
ask for my grievances to be redressed
it's the government literally saying
don't speak like what is there something
there is that not really a concern here
I don't think it's really a concern
constitutionally or in the long run of
course you know the Constitution
guarantees your right to assemble and so
on but but if we want to think of it
just as a liberty issue you know the
freedom for you to swing your arm ends
at my nose
you know the harm principle applies here
that in this particular case you know
assembling in a large group without you
know social isolation or you know six
feet distance and masks and so on does
put other people at risk so while you
want your freedom III should be free
from your contamination and so my
freedoms are violated and and so we can
we can talk to freedom versus freedom
rather than just freedom versus security
and that and
when you frame it that way I do think
this this is gonna pass
most pandemics do do wind down after a
while I think the most vulnerable will
have already you know suffered through
within say the next month or two I think
and whether we get a vaccine or not I
think we will get some kind of herd
immunity in the next year or so but the
problem is there's so much we don't know
I mean even though Chi he's not
omniscient know as much as I admire him
nobody knows a lot of these questions we
just don't know and that's of course
where there's a you know a vacuum of
causal explanation that's where all the
goofy ideas come in and in conspiracy
theories and alternative theories and
alternative medicine quackery cures and
things like that and they're all over
the place I've been writing about these
and tweeting about them and it's just it
pretty much every couple hours as a new
conspiracy theory and even Trump
yesterday was talking about you know
that's what the Chinese invented the
virus in a lab it very likely is a you
know a bat virus derivative from that
web market but they did they did do what
totalitarian states typically do which
is be you know dissemble and and be less
than honest and delay by weeks before
they admit what's going on much like
Chernobyl in the Soviet Union so that
this is China's Chernobyl and I think
they're gonna pay the price for that
probably with sanctions from other
nations again but again we just there's
so much we don't know well this seems
like ground zero for so much of the work
you've been doing for a long time now in
terms of the importance of inquiry
understand having a basic science
education knowing how to think
critically epistemological basics where
we we see I mean even with the the lab
thing as an example if this was was if a
mistake was made at a lab in China and
this was allowed to sort of get out that
does not in any way bear on Donald
Trump's competence or incompetence in
reacting right I mean like in my misery
South Korea and the United States had
their first cases within hours of each
other they dealt with this completely
differently whether it escaped avaya a
lab accidentally or not seems wholly
irrelevant
analyzing our government's response
that's right totally irrelevant yes and
you know Trump's easy to criticize
because he he stumbles so many times but
really it's not fair because whatever he
would have done it was going to be the
wrong thing to do in somebody's eyes
half the country size so you shut down
too early and then say in in early
February then he would have been accused
to being an autocrat using the pandemic
as excuse to grab more power which some
politicians have been doing like in
Turkey and Hungary in Israel and of
course already in China and North Korea
was already there so Trump would have
been lumped in with those and then if
you wait to if he waits too long and
then he you know he's a genocide I'll
you know maniac by letting people die
and you know so I don't envy that job no
matter what universal things like for
example South Korea immediately for
example developed a working test while
Trump said we don't want that test I
don't know that we need one yet we'll
make our own that failed South Korea
hired contact tracers right away huit
Massachusetts now is looking to hire a
contact raiser there seems to be less
controversial things that weren't done
yeah that that's right I would agree
with that and in hindsight we can look
back at the different countries
responses and use those as natural
experiments sort of a comparative method
that we that social scientists used to
see well this country did that and these
were the results and so I know they're
not perfect like Sweden for example it's
a very different culture and more
homogeneous much smaller and so on so
they're they're keeping the economy open
you know is maybe not comparable to us
doing the same in America so you have to
be careful on that I'd say South Korea
is a pretty good model you know they
they are a democracy they have pretty
good civil rights pretty good record of
civil rights and and they seem to be
striking the right balance so far but
again we'll see when it comes to some of
the stuff you talked about so we've seen
everything from here's a silver liquid
you can drink to protect yourself we've
seen claims of this is less deadly than
the flu we've seen videos go viral of
one or two doctors here
there who will say hey nobody else is
telling you the truth about this I'll
tell you the truth we don't need
lockdowns we don't need any other stuff
Bill Gates conspiracies regarding
vaccine like we've seen the full gamut
of it you know is this you've studied
this for so long is this something that
could be cut off with better education
in middle school is this a media based
problem what are the sources of having
this degree of disinformation spread
well the source of course the the
Internet and instant publishing and
everyone's our own publisher so
conspiracy theories can spread more
rapidly particularly in that vacuum of
causal explanation when we don't know so
this is kind of a perfect storm for
conspiracy theories I also like the 5g
one you know the sort of accidental
correlation of the rollout of 5g with
with the corona virus pandemic and again
people just glom on to whatever is
available and and you know the 5g it's
invisible and spooky and powerful you
know Bill Gates he's he's powerful and
so I'm old enough to remember when Bill
Gates was trying to take over the world
in the 90s so you know these conspiracy
theories about him have been around for
a long time well I think new research
since 2016 since the 2016 election and
the stuff about the Russian hacking and
the manipulation of social media you
know by BOTS and so on it looks like it
had very little effect on the election
itself or in people's opinions that is
people were already fairly divided and
that those kind of social bubbles just
reinforce what you already believe but
fixing the incorrect facts that are
posted there is not likely to change
somebody's mind because that's not why
they're there in the first place as the
line is that you know if you believe
that Hillary is running a pedophile ring
out of a pizzeria my correcting your
error and believing that isn't going to
change your opinion of Hillary as you
already don't like Hillary so I think
these kinds of conspiracy theories don't
ineffective in terms of the masses of
people and what they're likely to do I
think most people will do what dr.
Falchi says we should do who you know
even though there'll be a handful of the
people that try the the what was that
tank liquid yes that had
hydroxychloroquine in it as a antifungal
drug for fish you know that guy died
yeah that's so rare you know and in a
population of you know 340 million
people you know just point zero zero
zero one percent doing something crazy
is is enough to fill the evening news
but but but but not an existential
concern so how has the pandemic if it
all shifted what you think the
priorities for human should be over the
next five or ten years in the sense that
you've written about where where is the
future of humanity in terms of space and
you've talked about Mars you've talked
about your shift on your perspective on
guns of course you talked about free
speech and the limits of government has
any of what's happened shifted your view
notably on what the priorities should be
going forward yeah well I do think a lot
of cultural norms are going to shift the
handshake is probably gone for years and
it probably won't come back because once
those cultural norms are pretty fluid
and and they're not all that binding
perhaps even hugs will be gone but you
know we can make it up you know with the
yoga bow or the Japanese bow or
something like that and and people get
used to that I do think we're probably
for a long time be more sensitive to
hand-washing and and the cleanliness of
our environment both both at home and in
public places like restaurants stadiums
things like that and that's probably a
good thing I could I could project the
number of communicable diseases going
down just from those kinds of protective
prophylactic measures that we probably
should be doing anyway I think we've all
gotten kind of lacks about that I was at
that Vancouver TED talk TED Conference
when Bill Gates gave that speech about
the you know the next big pat debbik and
this is what he's worried about and all
of us were sitting there going yeah yeah
yeah yeah we've heard this before you
know not that we thought he was wrong
but just that like you know yeah I mean
people say this all the time and and and
even if it happens you know won't be
that bad and and in here it is so you
know I I think probably we should have
been in hindsight you know doing more
and now
we will and I think that helps I think
probably psychologically will more of us
will be appreciative of friendships
social relationships and contacts are
our immediate social group and who we
hang out with just because so many
people are kind of feeling bad missing
that social contact that you know zoom
and and online social media just doesn't
give you and I know you know yeah I'm in
California Gavin Newsom close some of
the beaches but not all the beaches
where I'm at in Santa Barbara the rates
very low here so the beaches are still
open it's a huge relief for people just
to get out and walk around and see other
people even if they're six feet away you
know that that human contact at just you
know within you know physical contact
not not touching but just visually
seeing people I think does matter I
think that's probably gonna longest term
effects so we'll be healthier you know
there's there was a study done just
before the Carano virus hit that the
average human body temperature of 98 98
what is at 98.6 degrees right it has
actually been going down over the last
century or so probably because the
number of inflammatory diseases that
causes body temperature to go up have
been going down just because we're
getting better medically at treating
these things so I can actually see body
temperatures going down less
inflammatory diseases which is good for
long-term health and and maybe people
particularly Americans and the obesity
problem this might scare people into
getting a handle on their their diets
and exercise and and more and more
people are exercising now that's a good
thing so even if the whole coronavirus
thing was was exaggerated and we never
had social isolate and workout and eat
so well well exercise and eating well is
a good thing to do anyway so that's not
such a bad thing no question about that
we've been speaking with dr. Michael
Shermer publisher of skeptic magazine
New York Times bestselling author the
latest book which we're linking to is
giving the devil his due reflections of
a scientific humanist Michael always so
great to have you on
nice to see you David you stay safe
there